mientras los líderes de todo el mundo se
reúnen en interiores para discutir las
políticas climáticas los activistas
protestan en las afueras de la sede de
la cumbre con 26 los manifestantes piden
menos palabras y más acción
no queremos oír lo que van a hacer
mañana solo queremos escuchar soluciones
solo queremos oír que van a actuar ahora
estamos cansados de que nos llamen
inspiración y de que nos digan que
mantengamos la esperanza no necesitamos
esperanza necesitamos acción previamente
los mandatarios se comprometieron a
reducir las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero y ayudar a los países en
desarrollo afectados por el
calentamiento global
mientras el secretario general de la onu
antonio guterres se reunía con
activistas de diferentes partes del
mundo advirtió que el papeleo era sólo
el primer paso
en los últimos días los manifestantes
han organizado protestas por todo
glasgow para llamar la atención de los
políticos y dejar claro que están
pendientes de las promesas hechas en la
cumbre
los líderes mundiales juegan con nuestro
futuro retrasando la acción y este nuevo
tipo de negacionismo está también
retrasando la acción climática y la
gente está muriendo por ello se trata de
un asunto serio y los líderes mundiales
tienen que hacer algo más que hablar
hemos visto buenos anuncios de la india
buenos anuncios sobre la deforestación
sobre el metano son cuestiones bastante
técnicas y complejas pero son
importantes
mientras los jefes de estado se despiden
de glasgow una cosa de segura
muchos manifestantes todavía no piensan
volver a casa
[Música]